Soros to back Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg I don't know why he
says sore roast backed but if he means
George sorospact we've looked at this in
detail remember George Soros funds
hundreds of programs one of the programs
George Soros funds is a pack that helps
to get DA's elected one of the DA's that
was helped buy that pack is Alvin Bragg
there has never been any contact between
Alvin Alvin Bragg and George Soros there
has never been any communication one way
or the other about a trump investigation
that's the connection that they're
talking about they want you to think
Soros is calling Alvin Bragg and saying
indict Trump